>> Alright, so let's start off, maybe you can tell
me what happens when Tit for Tat plays against always cooperate.
>> So what happens if you always
cooperate? Well, let's see, I start out cooperating.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And since the other person is cooperating I will
continue to cooperate because that's what they did the last time.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, I will always cooperate.
>> That's right. Good. Alright, so what
about if we play against always defect.
>> Well if we always defect, the first
time I'm going to cooperate because that's what you said Tit for Tat is.
>> Hm.
>> But from that point on, I will do what my opponent does, which
is defect. So I will cooperate and
then defect, defect, defect, defect, defect, defect, ellipses.
>> Yeah, so I put this always defect in there, but actually it
can't ever be the right answer right [LAUGH] because Tit for Tat always starts
off cooperating. So the, the other three seem like they might be possible,
always defect is not possible. Good. Alright. So, what if Tit for Tat plays
against another Tit for Tat?
>> Well, I started out cooperating my opponent cooperated. And since
I'm going to do what that person does I will cooperate, but
since that person's doing what I did, they will also cooperate.
And so we will both cooperate forever, so we will always cooperate.
>> Nice. So isn't that kind of interesting? So Tit for Tat
even though, if, when it's playing against itself, is a very cooperative fellow.
>> Hm, I
like that.
>> But if Tit for Tat is playing against
something that defects, it becomes a little bit more vengeful.
>> Yes.
>> Alright, so what if it plays against something that is
a little unsure of itself? So it starts off defecting, then
cooperating, then defecting, it's sort of almost an anti kind of thing,
right? So it's, this is one that starts off with a defect.
>> Right, so it always, so I, first thing I do is
cooperate. And then after that, effectively I do what the opponent does one
step before. So I basically take what you, I'm pointing to the
screen, you can't see me. I take the the D-C-D-C-D, and I
just put a C in front of it, because that's what I'm
going to do. So, I will do,
C-D-C-D-C-D-C-D, ellipsis. So that's your last choice.
>> Isn't the C-D-C-D-C-D, ellipsis in Atlanta?
>> It is, actually. It is the home of
all such analysis of diseases in the United States.
>> The Center
for Disease Control?
>> Yes.
>> Is that what it's called?
>> Yes, that's exactly what it is. Come to Atlanta and work for us.
>> [LAUGH] Alright, so good. So, that, that's the pattern of,
of responses that Tit for Tat makes against this set of strategies.
>> Oh, so we answered my question.